the Army's mission will not stop we're
going to continue to train within some
limitations this is very hard I'm just
gonna lay it out this this is hard hard
and that we're also going to continue to
train our mission
the kovat 19 crisis has already made an
impact on training at the US Army's
maneuver center of excellence inside the
Fort Benning military base new medical
screenings and protocols are changing
the way basic training is conducted
every year about 69 thousand soldiers
arrive at Fort Benning where future
infantry and armor soldiers go through
basic combat training the footage of
training in this video was shot when we
visited Fort Benning in February of 2020
before training was impacted by the
crisis as of March 28th six confirmed
cases of kovat 19 have been connected to
Fort Benning according to the army the
patients were not part of training
operations on March 24th Fort biddings
commanding general gave updates and
answered questions in a town hall
broadcast on Facebook live for the moms
and dads that are out there and all the
loved ones across America we do not have
any positive coping 19 cases in a
training base right now now I'm not
going to be naive and say that it may
not happen but we'll continue to screen
we'll continue to offer the best
protection and mitigation measures that
we can for all the soldiers every week
hundreds of new recruits arrive from all
over the country to begin their one
station unit training usually on buses
like this one according to Major General
Gary britto
new recruits will still be received amid
the pandemic at this point will also
continue to receive future soldiers
although perhaps in smaller numbers over
the next couple of months
according to Britta incoming recruits
get their temperature taken before they
board the vehicle that takes them to
Fort Benning and they're asked questions
about where they've recently been and if
they're feeling any symptoms we can make
the call for it when a person shows up
and they may be coming from one of those
states that is heavily hit like New York
State at this time
move he or she directly to a safe
quarantine location to ensure that we
minimize the risk of any Cova 19 spreads
as for the thousands of recruits
currently training at Fort Benning
training will continue albeit with some
limitations as you all know we're gonna
continue our training there's a lot of
measures in place to assist us and and
social distancing managing physical
distance and the simple risk that our
soldiers may be open up to as you can
see from this footage shot in February
some of the training requires physical
contact but because of the new health
risks recruits are being ordered to
incorporate a so-called physical
dispersion of at least 40 inches which
is a bit more than three feet between
themselves and other recruits
according to fourth inning training like
you see here known as combatives which
requires physical contact has been
temporarily suspended and for training
like military operations in urban
terrain or mout instructors are ordering
recruits to incorporate social
distancing as much as possible the
commanders and command sergeant majors
are empowered to keep those soldiers
physically fit keeping in mind the
dispersion and the group stuff just
needs to stop that is something that
will continue we'll have to continue to
monitor and stop people of the doing the
wrong thing perhaps the biggest impact
is what happens to the soldiers after
they graduate all visitors are
prohibited from attending graduation
ceremonies which typically happen every
week and the future timelines for
graduates ready to join the army remains
unclear as of now they will remain here
at Fort Benning and we're working with
the army through his apartment defense
policies on how and when they will be
shipped to their gaining unit I cannot
put a timeline on that now according to
Major General Britto
there is no shortage of space at Fort
Benning to house the graduates who for
now cannot leave and so far it's going
well for us but I don't want to be naive
enough to say that the threat was not
going to continue and we will mitigate
and treat it the best we can and make
the prudent decisions to protect our
force frame
civilians and soldiers included of all
ranks the best we can as well